la couronne nord demeure le royaume de
la voiture le transport en commun n'est
pas toujours une option intéressante
comme en témoigne cet homme qui
attendent l'autobus pour aller à
montréal
de mieux
dans le sud de lanaudière comme à
terrebonne repentigny à peine 6 % des
résidents prennent le transport en
commun chaque semaine alors que l'auto
solo est le moyen de transport de 80% de
la population
les citoyens veulent plus de transports
collectifs et souhaite la venue ce
réseau express métropolitains peut-être
que des fois j'ai délaisserait loto et
puis que je le prendrais je pense que
c'est une alternative qui est absolument
nécessaire et souhaité le prolongement
du rem de l'est dans lanaudière c'est ce
que réclame aussi les maires du secteur
qui ont organisé un forum sur la
mobilité nos citoyens pour le moment
n'ont pas d'alternative à l'auto solo
ils ont le train de l'est mais qui a
très peu de départs donc s'il avait un
réseau structurant fiable fréquents et
pérenne le les citoyens embarque l'air
dans le transport en commun éviter sur
place le ministre des transports
françois bonnardel confirme que le
projet sera étudié le rem serait
prolongée jusqu à mascouche ont le
rimerait possiblement avec le train de
banlieue déjà en service ce que le
prolongement jusqu'à mascaux je pense
que c'était très attendu il fallait
répondre parce que ses élus ou temps
qu'ils agissent sur santé ap l'orphelin
même si le projet n'est qu'embryonnaire
les maires de la région veulent y croire
donc on est très très très confus
par ailleurs québec s'engage aussi à
étudier le réaménagement du carrefour
des autoroutes 40 et 640 et ajouter des
voies réservées pour les autobus sur ces
deux autoroutes ainsi que l'a 25 on va
rester vigilant et on espère que
monsieur bonnardel va rester longtemps
au ministère des transports pour faire
le suivi avec nous là dessus à quelques
mois de la prochaine campagne électorale
le ministre des transports annonce que
plusieurs projets sont à l'étude de quoi
réjouir les maires de la région ils se
livraient bachar radio-canada repentigny